hey there guys so it is Thanksgiving day
here in was in the United States and uh
I haven't posted anything in a little
over a week and I felt kind of bad about
that so I thought I would rattle one out
for you guys real quick um this is based
upon a pattern that uh Ted from New York
posted in a video a couple weeks ago
wherein he goes from opposite split time
in antipin
to a horizontal cat ey versus ISO on
either side
like
so um I dig this pattern and I dig one
of the opportunities that it Accords us
which is that um the way Ted's doing
it as your hand enters into the
horizontal cat eye say your right hand's
doing it on the right hand side it's
really it's whichever hand is coming
down from the top I believe turns into
the horizontal cat ey and when it's
there in order to exit back out in that
four pedal antipin you have to switch
around the orientation of the poy head
and the Hand such that if your hand
starts on top and the POI on bottom you
can only switch back into the anti-spin
flower when the poy head is on top and
your hand is on bottom
right like
so
but it If instead we were to only move
around an increment of
180° we'd find that we can exit out of
this pattern in
extension like
so and once again we can use the inverse
of that pattern on the other side to
switch back into antipin such that we
can do extension antipin extension
anti-spin extension anti-spin extension
anti spin
yeah
cool um yeah really what makes both of
these patterns work is just as you're
doing this split antipin flower um
there's a point at which the POI kind of
meet in the middle wherein there're a
pois distance
apart and you can just close up the size
of the circle that you're moving in
such that it's no bigger than an
isolation
yeah and admittedly to get out of the
extension you really have to do
something more kind to like a stall to
get the point in the right place but I
don't think it's a deal breaker
yeah anyway so enjoy I'm going to go get
some turkey have a good day guys